we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P more and more people
asking about moving out of the country
take a listen to this
hi David so I've been so terrified of
the possibility of trump getting another
four years that I've been thinking
pretty seriously about how I would try
to meet the country leave the USA and
live in a different country if that were
to happen yeah um I just think that it
would be safer so I'm wondering if you
have any advice for people who want to
do that do you remember anything about
your own immigration from Argentina
that's right useful to to somebody who
is thinking about integrating away from
the United States well yes what I
remember is that there's a reason why
most people don't do it we he we you
know we've heard many times before if
Bush gets reelected I'm moving to Canada
if Obama gets reelected I'm moving I
don't know where they would go but in
any case
um most people don't do it because it's
insane I mean it's real it's really a
difficult thing it's as someone who came
to the United States still young enough
to quickly learn the language and
culture it is a really big thing to
abandon your home and um this is why you
know we shouldn't take lightly the fact
that people are willing to come to the
United States even illegally understand
the cataclysmic change that this
represents from them it is an
unimaginable change and I would be lying
if I said I'm thinking of relocating
permanently if Donald Trump gets
reelected but the truth is that it is
certain particularly now with the mobile
Studio where I can basically take have
the exact same sound and video quality
no matter where I go
um I am certainly thinking of if Trump
gets reelected we'll be here covering
the lame duck period and of course the
uh the re-election
um the inauguration rather but I am
looking at spending some months doing
the show from somewhere else and I
understand that not everybody can do
that not everybody's jobs are mobile not
everybody can afford it
um but it is something I am looking at
just to get a break just to get get a
break from uh being in a place where uh
constantly just idiocy is happening so I
I think that very few people are really
going to move out of the United States
if Trump is re-elected partially because
it's really cataclysmic change in one's
life partially because it's really hard
to do it it you can't just move to a lot
of the places that I think most
Americans would look to move to if they
are trying to avoid Donald Trump but
certainly I'd be lying if uh if if I
said it's not occurring to me to get a
break from the United States if Donald
Trump does get reelected but we'll we're
going to continue talking about that and
I'm interested in hearing from the
audience about it don't miss today's
bonus show there's another show for our
members membership is our number one
funding source grab a membership at
joinpakman.com and I'll see you on
today's bonus show